Hello everybody, hello, hello, welcome, welcome in, welcome,
welcome, part two of Portal 2.
Let's go, woohoo!
I messed something up on my computer.
Wait, never mind.
I have it.
Never mind, we're good, we're good.
I am recording, right?
I'm not used to this still.
Anyway, yeah, last time we just kind of been doing the
tests.
Gladys has been kind of leading us along.
And we've just been...
I've been big-braining and being awesome at everything I do.
Not getting stuck at all.
I know that.
I'm not getting stuck at all.
So yeah, I love...
I wanted to show the title screen, the menu.
It looks so cool with everything going on.
What is robot enrichment?
I might check that out later.
Community test chambers.
Are these like, you could make your own and then upload them
online?
That'd be kind of, that'd be kind of sick.
Let's just get back into it.
I'm excited to keep playing.
So let's go.
Challenge mode!
Oh my gosh.
They added so much stuff.
I've only done that co-op.
This next test involves Emancipation Grills.
Remember, I told you about them in the last test area that
did not have one.
Emancipation Grills.
What was that?
What are we grilling?
Are we barbecuing?
Definitely not me, right?
Surely not me, right?
You are the party!
Oh, oh, oh, what just happened?
Oh, oh, I jumped!
The turbulence again.
I have to go.
Wait, this next test does require some explanation.
Let me give you the fast version.
I'm the following people, so then I can find time to get to
see as soon as I can.
There.
If you have any questions, just remember what I said in slow
motion.
I'm sure people have.
I've already slowed that down before, right?
Also I didn't know that this was going to open up and I
jumped and I thought that like when the power went out and
everything, I was floating.
That was really trippy.
Okay so, um, that was so funny.
That messed me up.
Can I shoot through here?
Like this glass?
Oh.
Okay.
So this is...
Ah, okay, it's one of these where it's like...
I don't think I can shoot...
Wait, I could...
Oh, oh, so, so close.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, that was it?
Wait, what about the button though?
Wait!
And they give us this cool little...
Oh, it's a direction one!
And they give us this cool little hole.
Wait, if I go through this...
Yeah, I knew that was going to occur.
What we might need to do, okay.
Wait, oh, that's right.
I'm...
Whoa!
Okay.
You need to set it up here first, maybe.
Why do I stick it through the hole?
The square goes through the round hole.
I know my shapes.
Let's see.
Because if it needs to go into there...
There's here too.
I can't just make it easy for us, huh?
Okay.
This is...
What the hell?
How do I even divert it?
Like, where would I even, you know, because I can't bring it
in here, and if I...
We have...
Oh.
Because if I set it up in here with all the portals, when
I...
As soon as I pass through here, it's going to disappear.
You know?
Oh, this one's tricky.
We're only on test eight.
Out of 22?
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
No, we can do this.
But I can't bring the cube in here.
It disappeared.
Like...
Yeah.
Interesting.
And if I leave...
It...
Whoops.
It resets.
But I can't like place the cube somewhere.
You know?
Can I grab it?
Wait.
If it's like here...
If it's like so close.
Can I grab it?
Oh!
But then there's this hole, this mysterious hole.
It must be for something, y'all.
Are you watching this?
Are you entertained?
What the heck?
confusing me the most that I can't bring the cube in here,
so I don't know how
I would even direct it, you know what I mean?
And I can't even like...
Okay, hold on.
Let's just like play around with it, right?
Let's just like do something.
Oh!
If I have the cube here...
Oh, but even still, like as soon as I pass through...
It's gonna...
It's gonna stop, right?
Like if I grab the cube from here...
If I even can.
Oh, come on!
I didn't beat to...
I didn't win to!
How do I keep it?
So that it's keeping it open.
Like, how do I direct the lasers in that...
This one's tricky.
I thought I was stumped before.
I'm stumped for real.
I can't shoot through there.
Is there a way to get over it?
No, it's all glass.
I was like, do I do a momentum thingy and jump?
Oh no, people are going to be screaming at me in the
comments again.
I'm sorry!
Ew.
It does pass through this, though.
Wait, I'm stuck.
It does pass through this glass, though.
Oh wait, it just kind of passed.
Wait, can I do the limbo?
Oh my gosh, how low can you go?
Hmm.
Why does it pass through here?
Through this thing.
If I can't...
Whatever.
I'm not questioning.
I'm questioning.
But whatever.
Ah!
So this needs to be...
I was gonna say...
Can I jump in...
Shoot in here.
What the heck was that?
Who's rumbly tumbly was that?
You are my stepstool.
Okay.
Wait a second.
It's not even too directed.
Oh my god.
Oh, what the do?
Ah, yeah!
I just had to use my short brain to come up with the answer.
As a short person, I should have thought of that first.
Oh, oh my gosh.
We're at chapter three.
The return of hoops.
Oh, let me in.
Oh,
they're acting out.
Hello?
It's a lot of noise going on.
Alright.
Are you ready for me?
Whee!
Oh!
When I'm back, the aerial faith plate in here is sending a
distress signal.
You broke it.
I did!
There.
Try it now.
Okay.
What happened, right?
I was just lying there.
You thought I was done.
This plate must not be calibrated to someone of your...
This is amazing storytelling.
Yes.
I'll add a few zeros to the maximum weight.
Uh-oh.
You look great, by the way.
Very healthy.
Thank you.
Right now.
Big word, right?
Couldn't believe it either.
You seem to have defeated its load-bearing capacity.
Well done.
I'll just lower the ceiling.
Oh, you could do that.
Goodbye, Wheatley.
Goodbye.
Ouch.
One moment.
Oh, shoot.
Hold on.
I'm not ready for you.
And run and jump!
Oh, I should probably shoot a portal now, shouldn't I?
Is there any way that I can...
Wait.
Wait, none of these walls allows me to portal.
Okay, hold on.
This one does, though.
Oh.
Ouch.
You.
You over there.
You with the white wall.
Please, I can't see another one.
Ouch.
Please hit!
Please!
Ouch!
Wait, my blue one disappeared.
Oh, it disappears after I hit it too many times.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Okay, hold on.
Stop, stop, please.
I have the world's largest good girl.
question ever?
Oh my god.
Um, not to make any excuses or anything, but I did just wake
up a little bit ago, so...
Please, um, uh, have, have mercy on me.
Gotta get to there.
Oh, there's a, there's a button.
Oh, do I have to, um, Okay, hold on.
Let's do orange here and go back.
Okay.
Wee!
Ah, that gives us, that's a little cube.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
And then we gotta do the same thing again, but to the other
side.
Easy peasy.
Let's go easy.
Oh, good.
I keep doing it.
Keep doing it.
And then we'll redirect it to here.
But now my question is...
Now that that's powered...
I still need to jump up there.
I still need to do the thing... I still need to use my
portals.
I'm curious, huh?
What we could do is leave the square there...
And then I just re-portal them.
You know what I mean?
So...
We re-portal them.
We just... I just shoot them from up there.
ouch where am i oh look at you sailing through the air
majestically like an eagle piloting a blimp like an eagle
easy the eagle soars higher above the clouds
coffee time i didn't look up how many chapters there are in
this game enjoy this next test i will i'm going to go to the
surface it's a beautiful day out yesterday i saw a deer deer
camp if you solve this next test maybe i'll let you ride an
elevator all the way up to the break room and i'll tell you
about the time i saw a deer again we don't get to go out to
the deer why is the music so intense all of a sudden
What's going on there?
Making a pizza.
The pizza pie.
I think if I do this, I'll die, no?
There's also ones up here.
How curious.
And then...
Okay, that's for momentum for sure.
What happens if I do this?
Oh!
Oh, that was close, doll.
Wait, that felt pretty close.
Oh, there's something over here.
wait is that connect what the heck where am I supposed to go
there's so much happening here okay hold on I'm gonna drop
down oh it does connect interesting I just didn't notice
where are you trying to get wait what's behind there huh
what's over there huh saw something glowing.
I saw something glowing blue over there.
Okay.
It's, uh,
I gotta get my cube.
I don't even know where to go, though.
That's the thing.
I'm like, where?
Where is the egg?
Oh, there's a button up there that will drop something here,
it seems.
the shadows on the wall such a good like design it's so cool
let's start by doing that i don't see a way up there unless
it's the floor i don't know let me try let me see if i'm up
here
oh no i'm just seeing the lighting ah dang okay
so this is powering these which they seem to oh they're like
ah okay okay I see I see they are creating this barrier that
is making it so that I cannot fling over there so we need to
block this with with our own block okay okay
so I need to okay I see where I need the momentum from So,
we need a momentum from that wall.
Okay, okay.
Oh, that's not gonna work.
Why did it hit?
Did I hit the trash?
What happened?
Oh, so close!
Oh my gosh, so stinking close.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe higher?
Can we get much higher?
So high.
Allie-yup.
Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about, baby.
Uh.
We don't want to be flung back here again, so, uh...
We'll just do that.
No worries.
Okay.
you fling be free spread your wings and fly first
try maybe
all right all right that's what I'm talking about there's
still these ones on the wall though I don't know if they're
like decoration or oh they're not decoration oh oh oh oh Oh,
what's this?
Ah, it's a directional!
So...
Ah!
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
We need our cube.
We need our cube into this.
Alright.
Let's go back down.
Wait a second though.
Oh, I needed that one because I need to direct it over
there.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
We go back out.
Let's just put that in.
Nice.
And we'll do it orange here.
Okay.
Now you.
Don't get crushed now.
You go here with me, take you into there.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, all right, all right.
And we go with my cube.
And fly.
Wee-oo!
That one's pretty fun.
I like these like bouncy things, they're fun.
I didn't see the deer today.
Oh.
I did see some humans.
But with you here, I've got more test subjects than I'll
ever need.
So the world is not ended?
Just aperture science?
Gladys just loves working so much.
Sorry.
I thought that was corn.
Hard lights.
Hard light bridges.
Okay.
That's stranded?
Oh, it's like these!
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Wow, they're including so many new elements.
That's fine.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Yes!
The bridge, the bridge.
Okay, this is fine.
These bridges are made from natural light that I pump in
from the surface.
If you rubbed your cheek on one, it would be like standing
outside with the sun shining on your face.
Oh!
So don't actually do it.
Bye-bye.
So we need that.
Like so?
Oh my gosh, it's my runway.
Oh my god.
What's gonna drop?
From where?
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Aw.
That's, that's, that's a, that's a, that's a funny thing to
do.
Oh,
it doesn't go in?
What the, uh, maybe I, wait, actually, I need to, how do I,
I need to go back.
Wait, how do I go back?
Oh, here.
Okay.
Maybe I can grab it.
Is it in glass?
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
But if I orange that, I will die.
Maybe the orange.
Oh, wait.
What's that do?
Where am I going?
I just realized I go inside.
Hello?
Okay, we're trusting.
Trust, trust, trust.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's crazy.
Trust!
Oh!
I shouldn't have gone so low.
We're not gonna have enough.
Can I shoot portal while I'm holding this in?
time to try and out okay no oh wait i'm gonna lose my cube
okay maybe i'm gonna keep doing a little bit at a time to
try and get higher you know oh my gosh
okay maybe cube go here no no no no oh god i stand on top of
cube
Maybe...
Oh!
Yes!
There's no way!
How do I get up there?
Oh, wait.
Guys?
I think I'm stupid.
Guys!
I think I made it was my...
Don't even worry about it though.
Don't even worry about it.
I was making it harder on myself on purpose because it's
really cool to test yourself, you know?
To like...
To...
You know.
Wait a second.
Oh yeah, I could go back.
This is how the portals work.
You could go backwards and forwards.
Oh wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're thinking with portals and stuff.
Excellent.
You're a predator and these tests are your prey.
Yes, yes.
Speaking of which, I was researching sharks for an upcoming
Uh-huh.
Do you know who else murders people who are only trying to
help them?
Did you guess sharks?
Because that's wrong.
The correct answer is nobody.
Nobody but you is that pointlessly cruel.
Um, GLaDOS, I think we are forgetting the fact that you
almost put me in the incinerator.
Help me.
Also, I got an achievement for completing the first hard
light bridge test.
Yeah.
I think we are forgetting something that I was going to
become...
baked like a cake.
I know that my booty is big, but...
I figured out what to do with all the money I save recycling
your one room full of air.
When you die, I'm going to laminate your skeleton and pose
you in the lobby.
That way future generations can learn from you how not to
have your unfortunate bone structure.
It's scoliosis!
They're so angry.
It's so freaky.
Perfect.
The door is malfunctioning.
Oh.
I guess somebody's going to have to repair that too.
No, don't get up.
I'll be right back.
Don't touch anything?
Hey!
I'm here.
I found some bird eggs up here.
Just dropped me to the door mechanism.
Bird eggs?
Oh!
Bird!
Oh, so you trapped me in this room.
the bird in it that laid the eggs yeah okay look the point
is we're gonna break out of here all right very soon i
promise i promise i just have to figure out how to break us
out of here here she comes just keep testing remember you
never saw me never saw me i went and spoke with the door
mainframe let's just say he won't be well living anymore
anyway back to testing back to testing
Oh, it's telling us to use portals.
Oh my gosh, why didn't I think of that?
Why didn't I think of that?
But also, how do I get the portal from over there?
Oh, like this.
Can I hop on from here?
Oh, nice.
So, and then, okay.
Blue.
okay so blue no sorry orange is our color i'm keeping it
kind of consistent where it's like blue is the one that
holds the bridge and then orange is the one that i use to
you know get stuff so here should catch our thing right yeah
good job oh oh well that's fine
No, I do need you.
I need you to be in my stepping stool again.
Why am I so small?
What are these?
What are these legs for?
Okay.
Very nice.
Very well done.
Let's see.
Do you think I'm going to be able to pour?
Oh, I can.
Just kidding.
Awesome.
I didn't think I would be able to pour.
to see it but we did i crouch control or you know crouch
well like in minecraft and you don't fall off i'm going to
note this on your file in the commendation section oh
there's lots of room here oh wait did well enough it's not
burning off my head it's kind of make a cool sound though
the mosquito in your ear wait
Let's make a different sound.
Oh, don't push that off.
You want to take a dip?
You want to take a swim?
This next test involves turrets.
You remember them, right?
Yes.
They're the pale spherical things that are full of bullets.
Oh, wait.
That's you in five seconds.
Good luck.
Oh, no.
We're finally back to...
Look at how many are in there.
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
We're finally bound!
Oh no!
I'm like, oh yay, turrets are so cute!
And then part of me is...
Also like...
Oh no.
Put me down.
I don't hate you.
Critical error.
Deploying!
Ooh!
Target loss.
lost.
Get yourself.
Dang.
Can I sneak up behind them?
Can I sneak up behind you?
Wait.
Okay, hold on.
No!
There I'm not!
Here we'll do this.
We'll put it underneath him.
It's kind of sad.
Okay, awesome.
Anyone else?
Oh.
Yeah, but you can't get me, can you?
Can you?
Can you get me?
Okay.
Aww!
Hold on.
We could do this.
Oh wait.
I'm trying to find a safe area.
Can I shoot?
No, okay.
I have to...
We'll do like this.
For a first guy.
And then second guy.
Very good, very good.
All right, I'm gonna grab this just in case.
Are you still there?
Target lost.
Don't get me!
All right, now we can see the inside of the room.
So there's just three of them left?
Two of them left.
Two of them.
of them two of them um what if we did uh like uh orange up
here and then blue
their screams are too cute don't look at me
no deploying no deploying hold on i need to see again Okay,
so we can just do blue up there.
Blue is there.
Fire in the hole!
They're so cute.
Nice.
Oh, that doesn't seem good.
Uh.
See you.
So creepy.
Does she know?
Oh,
out of bounds.
I'm hacking the system.
To maintain a constant testing cycle, I simulate daylight at
all hours and add adrenal vapor to your oxygen supply.
So you may be confused about the passage of time.
The point is, yesterday was your birthday.
It was?
I thought you'd want to know.
Happy birthday to me!
I guess we have to get all three of these spinning out once.
It appears to be so interesting.
What's that door, though, you know?
So it's easy to get two of them.
The third one, What if I just like...
We must use portals!
I'm scared I'm gonna get zapped.
Oops.
You know how I'm going to live forever, but you're going to
be dead in 60 years.
Well, I've been working on a belated birthday present for
you.
Well, more of a belated birthday medical procedure.
Technically, it's a medical experiment.
What's important is it's a present.
I love it.
I love presents.
Are those all turrets?
Oh, geez.
Bye-bye.
We're going downstairs.
How deep does this go?
Like, how deep into the earth are we?
That jumpsuit you're wearing looks stupid.
That's not me, Tor.
It's right here in your file.
On other people, it looks fine.
But right here, a scientist has noted that on you it looks
stupid.
Well, what does a neckbeard an old engineer know about
fashion?
Not the neckbeard.
He probably... Oh, wait.
It's a she.
Still, what does she know?
Oh, wait.
It says she has a medical degree in fashion from France.
Not the France!
Hello!
Are you still there?
Oh, this is the platform!
Um,
wait.
There we go.
And they can't hurt me through this?
They can't?
No.
And I could start grabbing them too, maybe.
Oh.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, God.
I died with you.
I died.
This might not be the...
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
Sorry.
Spooked me.
I'm going to try shooting the orange.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, it did.
I thought...
I thought the bridge would hit the turret and knock it over.
That's what I was trying to do.
Maybe I can do that, though.
It doesn't seem like it.
It seems just, yeah, it's just in front of it.
Cute.
So cute.
Should you come over here?
Who's there?
Oh, okay, we have to have it like this.
Okay, okay.
I was like, maybe I can move it over a little bit so that I
can, uh, reach in there and start grabbing them more easily,
but...
This is the best I can do it, it seems.
I don't blame you.
I don't think I'm doing this correctly, but... Wait, what if
I can...
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, well, that worked.
Okay, that's one way to do it.
In my...
How to...
Portal 2 hacks.
Please hold me down.
Okay.
Hoi!
Put you in there.
Okay, holy!
Oh my gosh, there's so many in here!
Oh, they're guarding!
They're guarding the...
Come on, I just want to see what we have in here, what's
going on.
Okay, that's me, that's me right there.
So four of them.
Now where can we put the portal or this this guy?
to kind of block them, you know?
There's also a launcher there.
Interesting.
Okay.
There.
No, I'm not!
Oh, like this maybe.
Okay, okay.
So now...
They can't see me.
Okay, awesome.
That leaps me over to the other side.
I probably have to jump and portal the orange while it's
happening.
I didn't even look.
I'm so stupid.
They're a little confused.
Oh my god.
I saw me all at once.
Target lost, yeah, exactly.
Trying to figure out, maybe here?
I was thinking of maybe that would, I would hit it.
Oh, maybe I hit it here.
Like that, let's see if that works.
But then they'll still be able to get me, no?
Oh no, they don't, they don't.
Okay, awesome, awesome, awesome.
Ah!
They're all on me, they're all on me.
Are they on me now?
They're not.
They don't see me.
I don't, I just don't know how to Can they get me?
Can they get me through here?
I can.
I seem to be safe.
Okay, I have to, like, jump down and, like, grab it and,
like, take them all out at once, you know?
It seems.
That's scary.
Okay.
What I'll do is I'll use the cube and just, you know?
You know?
Alright, here we go.
Scary, scary, scary!
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's do it.
I did it!
I didn't see that!
You!
Oh my gosh.
I'm going through the list of test subjects in cryogenic
storage.
I managed to find two with your last name.
A man and a woman.
So that's interesting.
It's a small world.
Are you applying as my parents and they're...
My parents are frozen?
I'm related to Walt Disney!
I am the heir of the Disney Corporation!
Oh my god!
Is there still anyone named Disney?
I have a surprise waiting for you after this next test.
Telling you would spoil the surprise.
Oh my god, look, they have skins!
It involves meeting two people you haven't seen in a long
time.
Oh, they try... Oh, rainbow, cute.
Oh, I love the checkered pattern.
I'm kind of a sucker for checkered pattern.
Oh, the camel looks so good too!
That one reminds me of sushi.
The denim?
I'm also in my denim era.
Cute!
Wait, this is gonna involve more turrets then?
Oh, okay.
What does that mean?
The little...
The like...
The turret has crazy hair.
What does that mean?
Oh, I can't grab it.
I can't grab it in there.
I'm running.
Oh!
There's so many.
Wait, there's actually so many.
What did that do?
Ah, okay.
Maybe we can get them.
Where was it?
Here?
Oh!
Oh no!
I am!
I am burning.
That's what that means.
That's what the symbol... Oh, I see it now.
That's so funny.
No hello.
Grab that and then grab our other cube.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Are you still there?
Does it care?
Hiya!
Oh no, their cries are so sad.
Oh,
I need this.
Ah, okay, okay, that's what activates that.
Okay, got it.
Oh, I hear it now.
Oh, I hear it very long.
No, nobody can deny.
Why would she hum that?
It's kind of creepy.
The little children singing ring around.
the rosy.
Um, did you know the Ring Around the Rosy is about the Black
Plague and you would get a little...
Did you know that for he's a jolly good... It says this next
test was designed by one of Aperture's Nobel Prize winners.
It doesn't say what the prize was for.
Well, I know it wasn't for being immune to neurotoxin.
Okay.
I might be...
Oh, what this says?
Boom!
No more turrets!
Let's go!
Alright.
So I grab that and what's it do?
Oh, it activates that.
Oh!
Wait, what does this do?
It opens.
Cool.
Jeez, okay, this is, like, all timing, isn't it?
Ah, this is your fault.
This is all timing.
Okay, I get what I have to do.
So basically, I have to put the cube here, and then I just
shoot it somewhere else so it deactivates and lets the laser
go through, and then I'll be, like, over here on top of it.
Okay.
Now, how do I do that?
First question.
How do I get up there?
Okay, hold on.
We got this, we got this.
Let's just get back up there in general.
Right?
Right.
Let's just get back up here.
And I'm gonna go to this side even.
And I'm gonna go over here.
And we're gonna do orange here.
Like so.
And we're gonna do this.
Easy peasy.
And then we'll orange.
Like there.
I bet you think I forgot about your surprise.
I didn't.
In fact, we're headed to your surprise right now.
Is it cake?
After all these years.
I'm getting choked up just thinking about it.
I don't think Gladys has any...
Intentions to harm her.
I think Gladys has no bad intentions.
I'm stating that for the record.
I trust her.
Very much.
Oh, that's a...
Oh, the surprise!
We're in chapter 4!
I think I will call it here then.
Because beginning of a new chapter.
Well, that's...
I sure hope that...
the surprise oh my gosh aren't they so cute it reminds me of
the room and um rise of the resistance uh star wars ride at
disneyland that you walk in and it's all the storm storm
troopers that's kind of what it looks like oh gosh the
turrets are so cute though
yeah do you guys remember did you guys ever see when like
people would cosplay like GLaDOS and turrets and stuff like
they would kind of make like human versions of them and i
always wanted to make a human turret like a gingka version
of a turret and like a cosplay i already have white hair i
just have to i just have to i don't know like whoa wait if i
just didn't have if i could like die all my hair have no
mint tips which kind of look like a turret right now i blend
i I blend right in.
Wait, sorry.
I know when I exit out of the game, you can't hear it.
But look at me!
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to zoom in.
Hold on, hold on.
Yeah.
So good.
It's my cosplay.
I just need to make my whole outfit like black and white.
Like a traditional...
Wait, wait, wait.
Maid dress.
It would be so good.
Wait, hold on.
Okay.
Red eyes.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
This kind of is perfect, no?
Okay, hold on.
Ready?
This is so perfect.
No.
Wow.
Anyways, guys, thank you so much for joining me for part two
of a portal two.
And I'll see you for part three when i see you or to me too
thank you everybody thank you do chapter four chapter four
i'm gonna look up also how many chapters there are so that i
feel more prepared i don't have you guys in chat to be like
me too there's this many chapters and i'll be like oh okay
thank you but when i saw how long to beat this game it said
like eight nine hours so i definitely think i'm not like
very far at all i think we're just kind of zoom in a bit but
yeah thank you guys and i will see you later it's a bit too
it's a bit too bye bye bye bye bye thank you thank you thank
you bye bye